hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Shadows overloathing
I don't even remember where the hell we
are so I'm just gonna go to the new
places and there's a new place as you're
walking down one of ocean City's
residential streets on the way to where
you're going you hear eerie music coming
from the upstairs window of a nearby
house
well this is a good excuse as any so I
guess I'll go there
Zimmer's house this seems like a pretty
normal house in a pretty nice
neighborhood but there's something odd
about it some sort of uncomfortable
energy that makes a hair on your back
your neck stand up maybe it's something
to do with the weird droning tone you
can hear from inside like a pained
inhuman moan constantly rising in Pitch
maybe that's it yeah yeah it might be
that
oh my God you knock but you're no
response so you knows your way inside
that Eerie sound is even louder in here
it seems to be coming from upstairs also
the owner's interior design
sensibilities are a little strange
huh okay you hold the crap a bunch of
books about music theory even the most
basic one would be totally Beyond you
a day stand a Dusty disused chess set
today's stand no it's a chair
tea time was a long time ago there's
nothing left here but stains played rack
is a statement and the statement is I
have too many plates
cabin is full of backup plates trophies
for music competitions
you pull out a sheet but it's all in
German
[Music]
that was the worst German anyone has
ever heard in their life Bob would not
be proud of me okay well um Gabby you
have anything to
say about this
sounds like a cat meowing
yeah let's go upstairs I guess
[Music]
oh
hey bud I don't know what I was
expecting hey tired looking man playing
the cello
what who are you why are you in my house
sorry for intruding but I heard the
music and I guess I have an intrusive
nature the name's Marky plier well I'm
Ernst Zimmer forgive me for not stopping
but it is vital that I continue playing
what are you doing there's a Darkness
beneath my house did you check the fuse
box no I it's probably that then listen
to me I had a dream a premonition of a
dark rift appearing in my basement and
growing until it swallowed the entire
house and then the neighborhood and then
the world
uh surely it was just a dream though
it's not a dream I went downstairs to
check the basement and there is indeed a
rift as of now it is still small I must
keep playing this cello to prevent it
from growing any larger I was playing
the cello help the bass vibration
reverberates downward and is focused by
the circle of furniture downstairs this
resonance inhibits the rift I don't
really get it but okay are you a
physicist or something no I'm only a
cellist I cannot explain how I knew this
would work uh do you mind if I take a
look at the rift very well I cannot
blame you for wanting to see him with
your own eyes you will have to reach
into my pocket and take the key to the
basement for yourself as I require both
hands to play okay
huh
gave you this key so you could inspect
the dark rift in his basement probably
unwise but when has that ever stopped
you please do not get too close to the
rift
all right
um
sure there's a rational explanation
probably just a trick of the light well
I'm pretty sure your living room
furniture can't create reality
strengthening sonic waves haha you're
probably right just an old man jumping
in Shadows happens to the best of us
don't worry everything
uh oh
wait a minute
hi hello
maybe that wasn't the best idea
oh maybe convincing Zimmer to stop
playing his channel wasn't such a good
idea after all oh no
oh what have I done
play Man play uh I have bad news uh
remember how I said everything was fine
I do remember that yes are you telling
me that you were incorrect let's just
say that your house is incredibly
haunted ah I should not have trusted you
we're both fools did The Rift open I'll
go check I'm gonna guess yes though oh
God every one of the mouldering books is
titled blood oh no two ghosts playing
very spirited game of chess Day stand
has become a nightstand
oh no shares upside down frighteningly
non-right
oh vicious black sludge bubbles in the
fish office
we
nailed that
this isn't tea I got Eldritch
this is not tea
oh my God
chair is barely there
table is slip the Surly Bonds of the
floor Moss have eaten all the contents
in most of the container
a shelf of trophies for murder
competitions
chair is Whispering is it
sit in me in you all right you sit in
the chair for a few minutes and nothing
bad happens apparently it was all bark
and no bite just as well chair isn't
speaking to you ever again
oh what do we got you pull out a sheep
it's a piece of entitled all our bit and
no spill makes Ernst a dull boy
well I got a bad feeling about this this
door has seen better James
oh geez that sure if it's dark rift in
Space over there just like Zimmer was
afraid of well nuts huh
um all right I'm gonna tell him that is
there's definitely a riff there Zimmer
zimmy
uh I checked the basement and and
there's definitely a big swirling Rift
of Darkness down there yep oh no what
are we gonna do well if I were you I
don't worry I I'll think of something
well I'm out of here I've thought of
something and I'm done with this [ __ ]
I'm going home all right let's go fight
this Rift or something like that I don't
know come here are you I'ma beat the
Dickens out of you it's a big hole in in
here step in really yeah sure why not
I'm in you find yourself in an infinite
black void or it looks like an infinite
black void but you have an uneasy
feeling that your brain is only showing
you an infinite black void because it
doesn't want to try and process what
this place actually looks like it's a
weird feeling
oh interesting
thrumming Spike of negative energy
dampen I'm dampening it somehow
okay
all right I don't know what's with the
weird
wimbley well I'll talk to him you know
actually I'll talk to him come here you
come here are you all right never mind
then
[Applause]
how am I dampening this I don't even
understand this
it's working somehow
I did it
hello
okie dokie then
well I can't even talk to that guy so uh
did I do it
hopefully this leads back to the
basement and not you know anywhere else
it might be likely to lead like deep
space you're the middle of the Sun or 10
feet below the basement ore
hey look I'm in the basement
well I did it maybe
turns out I didn't do it
so there probably has to be some sort of
resonance with the energy spikes
um
well
so there I'm if I had to guess there's a
circle what
spooky so there's a circle of things
here
oh I got bubbling black sludge
apparently I'll go from The Haunted
teapot so if I had to identify these
things
the circle downstairs I believe relates
to the stuff up here right
that's what it seems to be and so
if I looked at it that way
I do believe this is indicative of the
things upstairs so there might be some
kind of a cluey clue whoa never mind
this creature is built more or less like
a large muscular person if you built a
large muscular person out of some kind
of writhing black ooze and or smoke and
or just plain raw Darkness it is if his
size glowing crystal embedded in its
chest about where its sternum would be
and as you draw near you can feel it
radiating invisible waves of energy kind
of like heat coming off a radiator
except also the opposite of that and
also not at all related to that look
incomprehensible forces are tricky to
describe okay the creature samples back
and forth waving its arms in a way that
almost looks like it's dancing or
praying now maybe just absent-minded
Leaf lailing it seems as oblivious to
your presence although that will
probably change very quickly if you try
to interfere with it like say if you
tried to pry the glowing crystal out of
its chest
okay creature looks extremely weak
almost docile
give me that
you make a quick grab for the Crystal
but it's firmly lodged in the creaser's
chest the creature howls and its long
spindly arms flail and effectually as
you barely cognizant of your actions
plunge your hands into murky flesh
fingers questing through lukewarm guitar
until they find ribs gritting your teeth
forcing open the cage creaking cracking
snapping like dry branches you grab your
eyes and tear free of the muck the
creature evaporates in a sigh of smoke
the crystal is both warm and cold in
your hand and has a slight buzzing I'll
take it something tells you the crystal
is very important as well as being
really shiny and pretty
all right yeah it occurs to you that
taking the weird crystal out of here
might be a bad idea on the other hand
it's yours now and you prefer to keep it
I guess I'll stay here for a mom
I guess
so what happens
huh there's definitely something good
you don't want to go too far at the rift
it would be a real bummer to get stuck
here for all of eternity uh okay so
I can't look at my
inventory whoa what have I always been
able to jump
that's something I can do
you know what it's my crystal I'm going
in
all right sweet I have go to sleep
[Music]
why is that my
ah whatever I'm taking it this is
probably a terrible idea oh it's still
haunted huh
interesting
hello
I got a weird Crystal check out this
neat Crystal I found that what is it
where'd you get it it was inside the
rift it makes me uncomfortable to look
at can I have it no it's mine you found
it inside my house in another dimension
another dimension inside my house forget
it it's mine well let's see
I guess what do I do what do I do let's
see as you start to leave the house
something tells you it would be bad to
take the weird crystal out of here that
something is definitely not the crystal
because it's a really great Crystal and
you're driving great satisfaction from
owning it
ah leave the house as you shut the door
behind you hear a sudden grinding
cracking noise and you turn to see the
entire house and implode into splinters
and get sucked into a whirling black
vortex can't say I didn't warn you
oh no
[Music]
it did warn me it did warn me really
really hard that I shouldn't have done
that ah
I get a feeling that if I try to get out
of this one I got a bad feeling that uh
I did something
up yep okay all right uh
distinct lack of house
well that's my bad but I do have no
there's no house there
um oh nothing hovers towards you I mean
something hovers towards you but that
something is literally nothing let me
try that again a thing that appears to
be a hole in physical space the opposite
just not just of matter but of existence
hovers towards you through it you can
see the faint twinkling lights of
ancient dying stars and the black smoke
drifting out of what appears to be more
of itself more nothingness or perhaps
anti-thinkness leaking into this world
is that a better description nothing
it'll have to do oh here comes another
one
oh Shadow Bonk no
all right well this is gonna go great I
have a good feeling about this
I have a great feeling about this
oh why'd they make a dude
[Music]
[Music]
why does he need to make a doo doo dude
foreign
you won the orbs dissolve into black
smoke and I don't know angst probably
okay good
I'm gonna go talk to
um
what was that whatever her name was
uh so I have this thing I got attacked
by some kind of weird shadow monster
like a sort of crazy abstract nightmare
thing yeah you've seen him nope never
murated though he did describe them to
me once did he add some kind of ultra
scientific name for them yeah weird
Shadow monsters is there anything I can
do about them well here take this ring
Murray gave it to me and said I could
use it to banish them if I ever got
attacked by one but I never have so you
might as well take it
okay that's helpful Maybe
helpful maybe better than this weird
ring I was wearing
well what's to do go to sleep I'll
somehow okay hey Mark before you go to
bed I need you to prove a new tenant for
the storefront next door what why is
that up to me someone's got to do it
there's three applicants for the place
okay what are they first applicant is
jar jard wears Hardware I guess if your
name is Yardware your options for
rhyming business names are pretty
limited second is La Table and chanti
it's like a high-end kitchen store
magical utensils and the like last
applicant is Texas Instruments guy from
Texas selling musical instruments I
suppose
uh
uh kitchen for my Cheeseman
okay
I guess that worked I'm gonna go to
sleep now
because I bet that I really did a good
job in whatever I was doing
well
uh this is in this is on fire even here
oh my favorite pants gone it's Jeff the
kid who used to bully you make amends
hey Jeff listen I just no hard feelings
okay I understand in retrospect that you
must have had problems at home and I
just want you to know everything is okay
now Jeff swats the overdue library book
out of your hands I see this is just a
dream version of you you're still just
as much of a jerk as you were in third
grade Jeff suddenly punches you knocking
out all of your teeth hey if this
actually happening I'd be really mad
I've got my teeth what a jerk
hello
what it's that creepy crimbo lady from
the refrigerator Factory now in a
literal nightwear form excuse me I need
to get past you why are you in a hurry
to wake up darling it's crimbo you
should be making Mary crimbo is still
months away oh but it's always crimbo
and dreams
oh Merry crimbo then Mary crimbo I
didn't have time to properly introduce
myself I'm dark Noel and in effect
affectation is Goofy as her name she
curtsies dark Noel huh you're really
taking this Motif seriously right down
to your weird evil looking grimo hat her
smile falters evil looking I told you at
the refrigerator Factory it's just a
wait she points to the weird device
she's holding at her hat it starts
beeping in a fast irregular pattern
you're telling me that you can see the
special crimble magic with your eyes
yeah if that's what it is this is
decidedly on festive news I'd better
talk to the president you want to talk
to Calvin Coolidge about your crimbo hat
I want to talk to the real president
about you I see yeah that's a problem
dear and I'll see you soon with the
solution she jumps off the edge of
whatever this is you're standing on okay
bye
I don't know what that was all about
whatever
bookshelf is not behaving the way
bookshelves do when you're awake oh
[Music]
oh the only way to interact with your
inventory during a dream is if you had
convinced Freddie to hold it for you at
the exact moment you went to sleep I did
that though oh I did
fine you got me all right
throw our way back into the waking world
okay
man these dreams are getting weird sure
hope
all right what's up hey nice hat
alarmingly a man in an expensive suit is
standing at the foot of your bed what
the heck who are you you may call me Don
Toblerone I represent a certain
organization of shall we say like-minded
criminals organized criminals like the
mob wait you're the dawn of the local
mob the mob boss in my room personally
no no no no no no no no I'm not the Don
this is merely my uh nomenclature it's
an abbreviation for Donald oh well
that's confusing it has been a matter of
some conversation yes I do have a sober
K but I don't care for it very much what
is it Donnie thesaurus I'm gonna Hazard
to Guess that they call you that because
you like long words there's various food
of you of course it's aesthetician comes
as no surprise to me my associators tell
me you handled yourself well during the
conflagration at the refrigerator
manufactorium and I'm here to profound
for your considerationing a certain
proposition come again I'm here to make
you an offer can I refuse it certainly
though your refusation would be uh shall
you say unadvisatory all right what's
the offer from time to time a
Collegiates and I have certain
requirements black the necessary
necessary manpower to achieve them at
such junctures we make lucrative
arrangements and with certain capable
individualists we find ourselves at this
moment at a juncture such as the
Junctions I have thus subscribed so you
want me to do contract work for the mob
exactingly no why not on excellent
excellent so what happens now just sit
tight as they say we will call upon you
telephonically he gives the current nod
then leaves the room through the window
it takes him three or four times to work
the latch
ah right I don't know what that was
about I'm not 100 sure what's going on
I don't know why I'm working for the mob
now
hey how'd you sleep uh fine until a mob
guy crawled in my bedroom window yeah
yeah window's pretty lousy anyway the
next antique I needed to find is a
compass the directions kind not the
circle's kind the detectotron says it's
out near Crystal dream Lake I don't know
where that is but I bet it's too far to
walk do you have a car I can borrow no
but I have something even better than
that two cars a bus pass stop out front
is your gateway to a whole wide world of
Adventure wow good for an entire year
that's swell thanks where do I go
unfortunately I couldn't get more
specific reading than near the lake
something about the place is making the
instruments go all screwy you take this
map okay okay there's a postcard now
there's a map of the lake on it it has a
picture of the lake on it yeah that's
what a map is a picture of a place I
mean I guess I I guess I can't really
argue with that I
I was about
carpet right right as a carpet who would
dampen The Stomping that makes sense hey
look whoa not yet buddy not yet for you
a blonde flapper cracks her chewing gum
then gives you a Sharky grin and a
little wave
hey there big boy you mock eye player
right who's he asking oh look at you
being all tough and mysterious well
Molly buttons is who's asking buck and I
do like games but don't push your luck
with me okay you got me so how do you
know my name but the boy sent me to lend
your hand had to keep an eye on you
Savvy what hey now I put in my two weeks
notice before I left pekeepsie fair and
square no no not that boss yeah poloka
the boss the boss you know
places over both shoulders and hisses
the mob boss all that the boss sheesh I
can't tell if you got a screw looser if
you're just funning with me I'd like to
keep people guessing so what are you
supposed to partner up with me that's
the deal McNeil and and do what that's
what's a 20-something girl like you're
gonna working for the mob anyway hey now
I ain't just a pretty face she pulls a
Tommy gun with a full-size drum magazine
behind her back gives it a flip in the
air catches it with a mad glitter in her
holy geez put that thing away
perhaps you have to whisper the boss but
you're fine with waving a machine gun
around in public so we teaming up or
what I've always got room for a gun
toting cutie pie oh you flirting with me
that's real sweet but I get a sweetheart
already and no offense but she's cuter
than you Shucks welcome to the party
anyway peachy you want I should come
with you right now cool my heels of
thumperdincks drink for a while you come
with me you got it let's hit the bricks
hit those bricks oh I see Gabby go well
okay Gabby Gabby can leave that five let
me let me let me chit chat with you a
little bit don't mind my uh don't mind
my uh shoes all right Chit Chat oh baby
it's the berries for sure where else can
you farm kale by drilling rats all day
and go out hoofing in your choice or
Josh I don't know
oh boy it's the berries for sure okay hi
I'm Mark ah bonzu my name
hesitate to ask man this my normally
incredible French accent is really being
thrown off by this great thanks are any
of your kitchen implements magical
I see you're a man of the sounding glass
for purposes
wow I keep playing
me but they will be happy to show them
to you that was for sale oh
do I have enough oh no I don't have
enough is there anything I could sell
there's nothing ever well I am unable to
do anything that I was hoping to do but
I'm gonna equip this because it was
better than my spatula and I can do
stench damage but if I had the other one
I would be able to do physical damage oh
well when I get when I get more money
I'll do that
all right to the bus stop what do you
want to take the bus Crystal dream Lake
please oh
apparently it's chapter two already I
feel like I've been jumping around the
stories so much
hello
some kind of funky pump contraption
light out from this house no but no
hello how are you Lighthouse Keeper
excuse me are you a light housekeeper
sorry to bother you my name is Mark
eplier I uh red leather yellow leather
red yellow leather yellow leather are
you okay I uh I just ain't talked out
loud in a while I get rusty I see
Lighthouse keeping's a lonely job huh
well it's solitary that's for sure I
ain't minded though ain't exactly a
people person
um what do they do well it used to be I
had to light the lamp every Sundown and
then Dows it again at Sunrise to save on
fuel used to be when it was an oil lamp
we got a hook up to the electrical grid
a couple years ago so now I just leave
it on all the time about all I have to
do now is change the bulb once in a
while sounds very peaceful ah that it is
nice and quiet and plenty of time on my
hands you must have a bunch of hobbies
got a book got a little knife plenty of
middle distance to stare into well how'd
you get into this have you seen an old
Compass the directions kind or the
circles kind directions I got an old one
I picked up an estate sale about 20 odd
years ago I reckon I show it to you but
it's upstairs and the lighthouse is
flooded flooded oh filled right to the
top have a look through the window there
to see you might see a fish pass by
how'd that even happen bump rope no I
mean how does the lighthouse just fill
up with water we aren't even below sea
level here something to do with the
tides I reckon this is a leak oh yeah
you need I need a glaxton valve to fix
the pump there's a hardware store down
the road a piece if you mind to help out
why is this my job through the window
you can see that the lighthouse Tower is
entirely filled with water the
Lighthouse Keeper has put a little cork
in the keyhole ah it'll do it do some
cooking oh
I can make things fancy foods yes
more fancy foods oh oh I don't have
anything
you want to play some uh chess did you
Whittle the pieces yourself six took me
16 years it takes you six months to
carve each piece pawns went quicker than
the tall ones but more or less a horse
are particularly tricky no sense in
rushing them wanna play a game can
already got a game in progress the only
piece has been moved is a single white
Pawn ew I went first that was about two
years ago who are you playing with
nobody
[Music]
well here I'll play you you push one of
the black pawns forward interesting it's
your turn don't rush me I want to
consider all the possibilities come back
in three or four months
all right
hi Mark bye mark single book War and
Peace huh that's a hefty one mind the
bookmark now of course oh it looks like
you just started been reading about how
five and a half years The Bookmark is
still in chapter one I just got up to
the last sentence of it I've been
reading one word every day War and Peace
is almost 600 000 words long yeah don't
tell me how it ends I won't let us
Keeper's bed is simple but very tidy
okey-dokey then I'm on a go to wherever
the hell this was
hardware store
oh Molly points out a sign posted a fork
in the trail ooh witches let's go check
it out you like the kind of spooky stuff
it's the berries get some blood pumping
well if they have a haunted house you
promise not to shoot any of the actors
no promises
I'll check it out on the way back
is right by the hardware store after a
short hike you find a small hardware
store nestled into sports wood
surrounding the lake it's the very model
of a Down Home Country Hardware Store
except it doesn't have any old timers
sitting out front chewing the fat maybe
it's their day off or maybe they ran out
of fat
hello I
you got any pump things
oh best hardware store selection of the
prices because it's the only hardware
store been a long time since the guy
usually that joke man I should have
spoiled it for you I'm sorry uh do you
have a valve Glaston was it a Glaston
valve pretty sure that anything maybe
something else was it a snackston he's
having trouble with his phone oh
glarston
it was
garpston
uh malston
Marston
something else glaxton blackston he was
glaxton it just wasn't Glaston well
Shucks they stopped making those nearly
a decade ago I guess there's a slight
chance there's someone in the back room
ain't been there back since the termites
got in the inventory or maybe after it
got flooded anyway it's a real Biblical
style of a disaster back there I'll
unlock the door for you so you can take
a look around if you want to find a
glaxon valve in that mess you're welcome
to it all right thank you I forgot I
have no shut up I have a shut up I have
a books wait
books I need to read them
oh
[Music]
pretty good but I'm not gonna get there
just yet read
medical Manchego huh that's pretty good
have I do I have 100 XP holy crap
I have a 107 unused XP wow
but I should probably focus on just
upgrading my actual abilities before
doing any of that nonsense I could get
subcutaneous gouda a thick layer of
cheese under your skin insulates you
from the heat wall so making you look
more muscular
well damn no no no no
I'm going to Blue Brilliance and I'll
get this armor you can relate to rocks
on both on an emotional level and on
being difficult to break an aft level
thank you thank you very much anything
that'll give me a bonus XP is probably
good wow it is a Biblical disaster here
good thing you don't care what month it
is because this calendar is worthless
seepage has always caused this concrete
to come see set in its ways blow its
mind you open the concrete's mind to the
wonders of the world that feels stronger
and more capable
powerful grid even though it's just a
nerd powder you're still pretty sure
it's going to bully you wow let's see
how much of a door has to be gone before
it doesn't count as a door anymore I
don't know
something wrong with this door in a way
that termites and flooding doesn't
readily explain
Dorian immediately feels sickening Lurch
in your stomach and a burst of this was
a bad idea in your mind like when you
hit the first drop of a traveling
Carnival's Rusty and hastily assembled
roller coaster after a moment when the
feeling is subsided enough you open your
eyes and look around it looks like
you're still in the same place you were
except someone came in and cleaned
everything up while you weren't looking
huh
fascinating workbench
workbench
an abrasive discus yes yes please
interesting huh there's a 1917 calendar
on the wall by the desk it looks brand
new
as you leave the store room the
shopkeeper spins around and you will
stare at each other in surprise you
because the shopkeeper looks quite a bit
younger than when he did you went in
there and him because Hannah what the
heck you were doing in my back room and
let's get back there without me seeing
you I'm uh the termite inspector I
didn't call for any termite inspector no
I do surprise inspections so the
termites won't find out in advance wow'd
you get past me I'm very good at my job
well I don't expect you found any
termites I make my own custom pesticide
yes it seems pretty effective I might
have to go back in there and follow up
check later though that's fine I suppose
just don't move yourself around too much
I like to keep it tidy back there
uh
uh interesting best hardware store in
the valley because it's the only
hardware store in the valley that's a
good one I'll have to remember that
I'd like to buy one of those new glaxton
valves ah sorry government fellas bought
my entire stock what ew for the Big Dam
they're building I can order you one
though how long would it take six to
eight weeks
would you mind holding onto it for me if
I'm knocking back right away oh sure
that's no problem how long you figure 11
years but what no forget how I said
that's not a problem well nuts listen I
can tell you they bought a heap more
galaxian valves than what they're gonna
need for that Dam if you go up to the
work site you might be able to get the
foreman to sell you one of their spares
where is it Southeast end of the valley
you got a map I have a postcard Crystal
dream Lake I never heard of that but
it's got a little picture of a dam on it
here there see that's about the same
place relative to here
okay
interesting this door doesn't seem to be
anything on the other side weird
ah I see why I need to go back to the
you to the present
present
hello
what do you have for sale oh you do have
things for sale I don't have any money
steel toed boots
people will hear you coming good
honestly great that's what I was hoping
for oh fuse I imagine I'm gonna need
that I'm gonna get this match
ooh comfy online
nice battery
no
goodbye I'm going to the dam well I
guess I'll visit the museum first
two of those hovering Shadow orbs float
up to you they look basically like the
ones you saw before that is they look
like nothing and perhaps holes in
everything but these ones move with
purpose and that purpose is Menace the
two are squint at you in dark Noel's
voice Echoes inside your head in a way
that makes your eardrums itch well well
if it isn't my favorite holiday party
crasher perhaps I need to be more
explicit about the fact that you weren't
invited I don't really get the whole
holiday thing I like crimbo okay it's my
thing and I'm sticking with it you must
have had a weird childhood you need to
learn to keep your nose out of other
people's Affairs I'm just trying to find
my uncle how about you keep your nose
out of my Affairs what a disagreeable
little urchin you are do you know what
naughty children find in their criminal
stockings socks
you suck dark
eyes one with each fist the orbs recoil
in pain that's it you're on the very
naughty list now next time we make I'm
Really Gonna deck your Halls
oh that's uh that's silly the village of
sandwich was home to a terrifying witch
cult until all the inhabitants were
convicted and executed in witch trials
in 1692 and the village stood empty for
years and uninhabited for hundreds of
years come explode to John and learn
more
hi what's wrong with your cat shelves
Laden with identical jars of off-white
stuff
the Danforth residence has been
converted into a gift shop for your
convenience why not take home a jar of
the sandwich cream which was The
Village's chief export besides
sandwich Cream Sandwich cream this
condiment purports to be the perfect
topic for any sandwich but the
ingredients list suggests that it's just
old congealed cream special piece of
paper is for making rubbings of
historical Graves damn I don't have
enough money
why don't I have enough money I've got
nothing to sell I need to wander around
a bit because I need all right I'm gonna
do some farming real quick because I I
need to wander because I need to extract
the oil I need to get money or meat I
guess stylish gel wow you'll never be as
cool as this slime it's a little a
little rude movement out of the corner
of your eye well nothing you were ready
to face a bunch of spiders or something
but there's nothing there but Shadows it
must have been some tree branches oh no
wait it's The Shadows the Shadows are
literally also spiders it turns out
burnison take that idiot oh
Crystal dream Valley Crystal shop I'll
keep wondering blue Cola
check the meat return slot damn on nuts
hold the line I stepped in some kind of
weird mushrooms spores all over my good
dancing shoes for crying out loud
dancing as in actual dances her back
alley shootout why'd I want a different
pair for each they ain't that dissimilar
okay I got spores see familiar looking
person as I get nearer you realize the
reason he looks so familiar is because
he looks exactly like you hi are you a
clone or is this a Time Paradox turns
out it's a Time Paradox I guess wow
crazy I agree high five
you lean in for a kiss no tongue
is there anything smooch wink now you
get to look forward to a second one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you still building your Gap in the trees
there's a large sign painted on the side
of the building that says quality
Spirits so presumably it's either a
Distillery or a ghost farm
I'm Gonna Keep wandering on
God damn that was great okay it's
Shadows banish them ah damn I'm good I
have gotten no meat though
oh red sunshine you catch a glimpse of
large gaily colored butterflies nearby
you move towards them slowly so not to
startle them as you get closer you
realize that instead of having regular
insect bodies they're little people
fairies wow hello there gosh you're
really beautiful you're beautiful that
sounded just like my voice are you guys
mimics that's real ah it's on my face no
not my eyes are
what what the hell you swat away the
ferry that had fluttered up next to you
and attempted to stab you in the neck
with a rusty needle
Kerry is approaching lugging a full-size
snub-nosed revolver
man I need to get Bewitched I'll fight
him though yeah this is what you get I
oh mine melt interesting twig Thumper we
got thump Grady okay I can I can finish
you off and I can finish you off with
two attacks yeah
oh
my God
[Music]
actually I should have checked if any of
them have high mysticality because I
think that's what mine yeah that's what
mind melt does but I can still Mash two
of these dudes
take this
that's what Garlic's all about
what oh hi that's not what you intended
to do
oh shoot random enemy one for seven
times holy crap got a knee captain
I just shoot him a bunch
nice
oh I hate that
no Grady no
all right you're done for now I think
take one of these
dude I have psychic powers
and then shoot him a bunch
man a gun really is a great thing fairy
dust okay follow the trail of fairy dust
fairy Lair all right I still need to
farm
okay me finally need more meat mushroom
cave nope man I didn't even wander in
the last area I should have wandered
more let's see well I picks up a flat
stone skims it expertly nice one thanks
hey Buck how big a rock do you think you
can Chuck raw muscle isn't exactly my
forte but I guess I'll do all right you
pick up a fist side rock and pinch it
and Pitch it into the lake with a splash
allowed Planck Falls soon behind you
turn to see Molly picking up a softball
sized rock with a grin that's impressive
I may look girly girl but my Tommy's
gotta kick like a mule gotta keep the
rust off of these Pistons you know is
Tommy your boyfriend that sounds kind of
my girlfriend's name is Nancy Tommy is
short for m1921 Thompson submachine gun
ah I see well Molly is now stronger
which is great familiar looking person
oh good wow nice he leans in for a kiss
goodbye
now you get to look forward to a circle
I'm glad I saw that all right me return
slot I don't want a blue Cola I need to
farm my meat Greta's compassionate pet
store I don't trust that
red Cola empty
damn drink it for your country
I'm not going to I'm all right
check the drawer oh matches oh all right
Beppo's hole check out the terrible I'm
gonna I'm gonna go check out Beppo's
hole I'm gonna check out the terrible
spider roll
that sounds like it might have something
for me there aren't as many spider eggs
in here as there could be but there are
still too many
the plexus Beppo's hole at the top and
there's some fine print peppo's hole is
named after Beppo P saricho who
purchases plot of land in 1903 with the
stated intention of creating a shark
Sanctuary he managed to dig one decent
sized pit but before he could fill it up
with sharks I filled itself up with
spiders or perhaps it would be more
accurate to say that the spiders filled
it up themselves and their offspring
they're teeming hordes of awful venomous
Offspring it is the opinion opinion of
the crystal dream Lake historical
society that Beppo's hole should be
avoided at all costs in fact we probably
shouldn't have put this placard here or
included on any of our Maps May those
you leave behind forgive us
oh good definitely a lot of spiders in
here oh well hold on let me look at this
weird wriggling cocoon it's roughly
person size it's either a person who's
slowly been cocooned by a spider and is
slowly suffocating to death or a
person-sized mass of baby spiders talk
to him heard them
hello are you a person or a
mind-breaking quantity of baby spiders
is that the kind of noise a whole lot of
baby spiders would make
all right I'll cut them free you've cut
apart the Cocoon bracing yourself for
true horror fortunately it turns out to
just be a guy in there oh thanks friend
you had me worried for a sec they call
me Doc I came here for to get some free
gauze got a bit more than I bargained
for hi doc I'm Mark I assume you're a
doctor hat thing that you're literally a
doctor in a sense that doctoring is my
profession yes in the sense that I have
a legal license for practicing it no
you're looking for gauze yep the webs
from big spiders like this make really
great surgical gauze strong
self-adhesive and even sterile if it's
really fresh unfortunately I bit off
more than I could chew you can chew it
too no I'm at metaphorically one of the
great big spiders that live in beppa's
hole caught sight of me I don't
recommend messing around with that hole
especially if you're flush to the gills
on medicinal alcohol I see ask him about
hobo code can you teach me hobo code oh
cool
uh there's a camp you could go to the
camp I'm much too eager to get doctor oh
I could use some patience I'm much too
eager to get doctoring that's a joke
that works better out loud than in print
anyways either okay goodbye I guess good
thing I checked for code first
this is you're going not well
owie
why this might have been a mistake
um how much mysticality you guys got uh
too much interesting interesting well I
can definitely kill one of you intends
to give birth to something terrible no
no no no
no no all right I'm gonna cook one of
you
and then I'm gonna heal and cure myself
focus at a Marcus
and then I'm gonna do a surplus Cola
Wars grenade to kill you and make sure
you don't birth anything
and then I'm going to garlic
[Music]
oh it's horrible no
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
good good well
I'm gonna melt your brain
all right so kill you
good oh I should have hit that one with
oh with her because her she does seven
right that would have been good
that would have been smarter but I'm not
smart kill
I got with spider webs
fewer spiders is better spiders good I'm
not gonna fight anymore I need to get
more meat I've gotten
the future version of you strolls up to
you and hands you a fat wad of meat you
know it's the future version and not the
past version because you don't remember
this happening before here take this
meat technically I guess I should be
repaying it to the Future me but that's
me now so you'll have to do what but
what's the point in giving me meat if I
have to give it back to me later you'll
be making meat much more easily later so
this won't seem like as much then just
think of it as a no interest loan on the
contrary I actually am interested he
rolls his eyes at you sheesh feature you
is a jerk yeah anyway don't forget to
pay you back or the universe will
probably explode or something all right
I have money do I need to pay myself
about
300 me Mama Jama I gotta go I gotta go
don't take my money me okay
who solved the maze wait well I'm short
having nearly walked straight into a
huge spider web while you weren't paying
attention although I guess some part of
you was paying attention good job
whatever part that was you turn ahead in
another Direction and soon find yourself
stopped by another big spider web so you
turn around to try another Direction
nope that path ends in the big spider
web looks like the attention paying part
of you wasn't paying enough attention to
keep you from getting lost in the huge
spider web maze maybe in the future you
should pay attention to these things
solve it I'm so smart spider says Shucks
all right so now that I'm here I finally
can get things that I probably am going
to need in the future like rubbing paper
and sandwich cream
I don't know why I need it but I need it
hello nice hat nice hat
what's the exhibits here sorry I just
get paid to stand here keep an eye on
things I don't actually know anything I
guess all right sure
old book a little description Diary of
Delia Putnam 6th of March 1692 oh God
hit that Peter Proctor so much he thinks
he can just go around being as mean as
he wants just because he has lots of
money and lives in a big house I should
have used a much stronger curse would
have more the trouble okay antique
Ragdoll a bunch of old pins some reason
the word boring improverted little
plaqueses which is frequently use
special dolls called puppets to curse
their enemies this one is apparently
made to a target of Misses or Miss
boring though none of the names seem to
be listed the pins were not found with
the puppet but were added for
demonstration oh all right goodbye why
did I come here I have no idea
nice gazebo plant matter in these dubs
proved they were used to brew all kinds
of horrible poisons
fried fronds
check the footnote point out to us okay
is any of this important go up to the
second and a half floor
uh uh interesting
[Music]
oh wow okay I did all this for nothing I
did all of it for nothing was the
Outhouse is great wow
I'm availing myself
[Music]
all right okay
little Cemetery all right good
Peter Proctor he was a duty head until
the very end Nicholas Proctor what the
heck he lived to be 230 years old
Proctor
oh oh I'm so close to knowing that I
have that thing of the rubbing paper nah
all right I don't know why I came here I
don't know why I did any of this why did
I do this I'm going to the dam screw all
this nonsense that I don't need to know
about I don't need to know
what's this full never race a rodent I
don't have nearly enough Moxie for that
this what do you call it is huge damn
I'm fishing in a pipe
you caught oh
oh okay welcome to do fishing okay I can
sell that at least that's good caught
everything that was in there boring
our glass skin valve the valve is had in
place by Decades of corrosion even if
you could detach it he'd get wrecked in
the process
well damn literally nasty goo awesome
rabbit
ah damn hobo code can't
um seems to be a maintenance maintenance
access to an ethereal Dimension well
before I do that I'm gonna have to end
this episode for now because I'm out of
time we will just have to go back in
time and talk to our time Bearer toxic
ourselves and hopefully never give
ourselves money again in order to be
able to solve this I'm not going to
break the space I'm Continuum by saying
that there won't be an episode in the
future because there will be but you're
watching this in the future when I
recorded this in the past so thank you
for watching when you did and when you
will and as always I will and won't
never not see you in the future and past
when I see you bye-bye
[Music]